you've done the Golden Globes before and
you can be quite edgy and are the
celebrities do you think the celebrities
out there are nervous they're nervous
about they're gonna be sitting there
what will Rickie say about I think so no
one wants to be the butt of a joke but
you know I'm not gonna go I'm not trying
to ruin their night I'm making jokes you
know
and also I'll do it about things they've
done not you know not other things they
can't help so you know I think I'm fair
you know I mean no no you're not you're
not making fun of a way they look I
wouldn't come out and go oh look it's a
ginger Frankenstein so you're not gonna
do that I'm not I do that no no but you
wouldn't do that it's because they did
say they got me back I said no at first
I was too busy and they said the magic
words you can say what you want again I
went okay I mean right yeah and you
write jokes and even I feel with jokes
and I'm doing I'm writing jokes and like
no I can't do that that's too much and
it really bugs me cuz I may be able to
do I'm here no one's watching this yeah
that's a nice point that your there's
really no one watching so you might as
well that's part of this show yeah say
people love this show cuz there's no
pressure
well is one joke I thought of the for
the first joke I thought of when I said
yes to host a Golden Globes I wanted to
come out and say welcome to the Golden
Globes why is this show like a female
elephant it too has a massive
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so self-deprecating dears you get in
dears you that makes everyone go oh I
like it
let go you're not you hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please